YEAH. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS
BACKER PORGES THE BRADFORD HAVE
ADAM ATTENDEES. DALLY THE RISER
EGGS. GROW HERTZBERG WAY SO HER
TADO JONES LAYERED LABOUR WE
NOW OWN MCGUIRE MELINDA. NEWMAN
WE ALSO BUT SHOW A BOGUS CAN
POURTANT. RIGHT RUBIO SKINNER
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE WEINER WELK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. BY SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK YOU LOVING GOD OF MERCY
AND JUSTICE WE CELEBRATE TODAY
THE BIRTH OF REVEREND DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. AND WE'RE
REMINDED MORE THAN EVER OF HIS
WORDS TO US. WE ARE TIED
TOGETHER IN A SINGLE GARMENT OF
DESTINY. CLOT IN NXT PURPLE
NETWORK OF MUTUALITY AND
WHATEVER AFFECTS ONE DIRECTLY
AFFECTS ALL INDIRECTLY.
MYSTERIOUS GOD IF THIS IS THE
WAY OF OUR UNIVERSE IS
STRUCTURED THEN MAY WE REFUSE
TO BELIEVE THAT WE'RE UNABLE TO
INFLUENCE THE EVENTS THAT
SURROUND US MAY WE REFUSE TO
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE BOUND TO
RACISM. AND WAR. THE JUSTICE
MPS ARE IMPOSSIBLE. MAY WE
LEARN TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PRIVILEGES OF SOME. OF US COME
TO ACCEPT AT TECH NORMA'S COST
OF OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. IN THIS
YEAR OF COVERT NINETEEN HAS
MADE OUR WORLD ONE NEIGHBORHOOD.
MAY WE HAVE THE ETHICAL
COMMITMENT TO LIVE TOGETHER
AWARE OF OUR INTER DEPENDENCE.
ONE ANOTHER. THROUGH YOUR
GOODNESS AT WORK WITHIN EACH OF
US MAY WE REACH OUT WITH
HEALING HANDS TO ONE ANOTHER
WITH THIS WE ASKED IN YOUR NAME
ON THAT. WE BELIEVE IT'S-
GOING. TO THE FIVE HAVE YOU
NOTICED OF AMERICA. THE
REPUBLIC WHICH- ONE NATION.
INDIVISIBLE LIBERTIES JUSTICE.
FOR MEMBERS TDAY WE SENT BATES
GLAZIER AND SOLACE MEN AND
STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD MORNING SENATORS. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED TO READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED RED.
WORDS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED TO READ. AND MOVING ON
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THERE IS A
LETTER AT THE DESK REQUESTING
WITHDRAWAL OF SENATE BILLS
EIGHTY FIVE TO EIGHTY NINE. AND
NINETY ONE THROUGH NINETY FIVE
FROM THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
GIVE THEM THEIR SECOND READING
IN ORDERING THOSE BILLS TO
THIRD READING. THANK YOU. THERE
ANY OBJECTION OBJECTIONS IN ANY
CASE- COMMENT OR QUESTION ON
THIS ISSUE. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR NIELSEN. YES IF
I MAY WELL THE PRESIDENT OR
THESE TO BE BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS OR WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
THESE BILLS THAT ARE BEING
BOUGHT AND MASTER THE FOUR.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. BUDGETARY
BILLS THANK YOU SIR THEN I
WOULD OBJECT. TAYLORVILLE AT
THE OCCUR ON OUR BUDGET PROCESS.
THEY SHOULD BE MORE THOROUGHLY
REVIEWED AND NOT FAST TRACKED
AND THERE SHOULD BE FAR FEWER
OF THEM I OBJECT AND ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL VOTE. VERY GOOD HI
THERE'S A MOTION TO WITHDRAW
ROLL CALL PLEASE. WITH FALLON.
HI. IT'S A MOTION MADE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I BACKER.
HI FORGES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
YELLOW I COURTESY. HI DOLLY NO
DOT. DODD HI TORONTO BY ADMIN I
DROVE NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO.
HER TADO. JONES NO LAYERED I
LABOR I THE MON. MCGUIRE I AM
DOES HELLO NEWMAN. I NIELSEN.
NO A TRIO OF BOTH. NO PAN HI
POURTANT TINA. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. AMBERG I Y.
CASKEY FIVE WINNER I WILL. NO.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WAY SO. HER
TADO. THE MON SKINNER. TWENTY
TWO EYES A NOSE THE MOTION
PASSED THE MOTION CARRIES.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ITEM
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS THE BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED DREAD WILL MOVE ON TO
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND READING MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS. MOVING ON TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING SENATOR
BRADFORD. SECRETARY PLEASE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIX BY
SENATOR BRADFORD RELATIVE TO
REVEREND DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND LET ME SAY THANK
YOU TO OUR- HM AND MY
COLLEAGUES I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS THE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
I'M HONORED TO. RECOGNIZE THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO REALLY SHOULD BE
ACKNOWLEDGES CRY WHEN THE
GREATEST AMERICANS WHO HAVE
EVER LET INDIVIDUAL THAT'S
UNDISPUTED THAT HAS DONE MORE
NOT JUST FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
BUT ALL AMERICANS DURING THE
SHORT THIRTY NINE YEARS OF HIS
LIFE A LIFE AND LEGACY THAT WAS
DEDICATED TO NONVIOLENCE AND
THE STRUGGLE FOR RACIAL
EQUALITY IN UNITED STATES AND
ABROAD. AND FAR FROM THE
INSANITY THAT WE SAW LAST WEEK.
DR KING MARCHED AND
DEMONSTRATED AND PEACEFUL
EVENTS ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
IN WHICH- L. FOR MORE HARSHLY.
THAN THE TYRANTS THAT RAN INTO
OUR CAPITAL LAST WEEK ON THIS
DATE IN NINETEEN TWENTY NINE DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS BORN IN
ATLANTA GEORGIA. YOU WERE ALIVE
TODAY HE WOULD BE NINETY TWO
YEARS OF AGE. MANY DO NOT
REALIZE HIS BIRTH NAME WAS NOT
MARTIN LUTHER IT WAS MICHAEL.
AND IT WAS NOT UNTIL HIS FATHER
WENT TO EUROPE. AND VISITED AND
SAW. ANTI **** MOVEMENT AND ALL
THE OTHER MOVEMENTS OF SOCIETY
THAT HE TALKED TO CON THE
TEACHINGS OF MARTIN LUTHER AND
TOOK ON THAT NAME. AND MARTIN
LUTHER KING WAS. TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS OLD BEFORE HE HAD HIS
NAME LEGALLY CHANGED TO MARTIN
LUTHER KING. IT HAS BEEN FIFTY
THREE YEARS SINCE HIS DEATH- HE
WAS ASSASSINATED AS WE ALL KNOW.
AND SELMA. I MEAN METHODS I'M
SORRY IN MEMPHIS TENNESSEE AT
THE LORRAINE MOTEL. A MOTEL IN
A ROOM THAT I WAS AFFORDED TO
VISIT SOME. THIRTY YEARS AGO
THIS GREAT MAN'S LIFE CHALLENGE
THE SPIRITUAL MORAL COMPASS OF
THIS NATION. CREATING A SURGE
OF CHANGE RELATED TO FREEDOM
JUSTICE EQUALITY FOR ALL HUMANS
I HOPE THAT ALL MEN AND WOMEN
REGARDLESS OF THEIR COLOR.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR CREED
REGARDLESS OF THEIR RELIGION
WOULD BE AFFORDED THE PROMISE
OF THIS COUNTRY. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE. THE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON AND HIS GREAT SPEECH
I HAVE A GREAT DREAM DR KING
CLEARLY STATED. THIS COUNTRY
HAS WRITTEN A NEIGHBOR A
PROMISSORY NOTE. THAT IT'S COME
BACK INSUFFICIENT FUNDS. WERE
STEELED DEVOID OF THAT PAYMENT
TODAY TO THE NEGRO PEOPLE.
SALLY AGAIN WE'RE STILL
STRIVING TO THE GOALS OF DR
KING. ON MONDAY WE HAVE THE
LUXURY OF HAVING A DAY OFF FOR
A HOLIDAY NAMED AFTER. A
TRANSFORMABLE TRANSFORMATIONAL
FIGURE AGAIN DEDICATED TO
REFLECTING ON HIS LEGACY
SACRIFICES AND HIS LOSS BUT
THIS SHOULDN'T BE A DAY OFF BUT
IT SHOULD BE A DAY ON A DAY OF
SERICE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT DR
KING'S LIFE WAS ABOUT SERVICE
HE OFTEN STATED THE MOST
PERSISTENT AND UGENT QUESTION
IS WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR OTHERS
I ACTUALLY TODAY WHAT ARE WE
DOING FOR OTHERS MY COLLEAGUES.
TO FIGHT TO ENSURE OUR NATION
TO OBSERVE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR HOLIDAY RESEMBLES THE
STRUGGLES FOR KNOWLEDGE MEANT
THAT AFTER AMERICANS HAVING
DORK SINCE ARRIVAL TO THIS
COUNTRY. TODAY WE ARE ALL IN
THIS COUNTRY. BENEFIT FROM THE
WORKS OF THIS GREAT MAN WHO
MADE IT HIS LIFE'S GOAL. TO
SERVE AND ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THOSE WITHOUT A VOICE.
REPRESENTING THOSE
HISTORICALLY. MARGINALIZED AND
HAVE LACKED ADEQUATE
REPRESENTATION. DR KING'S
COURAGE AND DETERMINATION
REMAINING INSPIRATION AND
MOTIVATION FOR MANY LIKE ME WHO
GREW UP DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. THE FIRST TIME I'VE
EVER WITNESSED MY FATHER'S
CRIME WAS AT THE SOUTH DIVISION
AND ADOPT A MARTIN LUTHER KING.
HAS NOW THE ONLY SINGLE. BLACK
MEMBER OF THE SENATE I STAND
HERE TODAY ON THE SHOULDERS OF
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING WITHOUT
HIS GREAT SACRIFICE. I'M NOT
SURE IF I WOULD BE HERE TODAY
ARE MANY FOLKS WHO LOOK LIKE ME
WOULD BE AN ELECTED POSITIONS
OR POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY. HIGH
AND I'M HONORED TO REPRESENT
NEARLY A MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS
GREAT STATE. DR KING LET THE
MODERN CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT
FOR ALMOST THIRTEEN YEARS. FROM
HIS ELECTION AS SPOKESMAN OF
THE MONTGOMERY IMPROVEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN DECEMBER OF
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE UNTIL HIS
DEATH. A MOVEMENT THAT IS THE
CREATOR IS THE BLUEPRINT FOR
ALL OF OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENTS WHETHER IT'S WOMEN'S
LGBT IMMIGRATION IMMIGRANT
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ARE NATIVE
AMERICANS IT IS THE BLUEPRINT
AND THE SHOULDERS ON WHICH ALL
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENTS. STAND
ON. THIS MOVE IT AGAIN HAS THE
BLUEPRINT. FOR FIFTY YEARS. AND
WE'RE PROUD TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THAT. SAME VEIN OF
DOCTOR MARTHA KING UNDER DR
KING'S LEADERSHIP HE HELPED A
MAN AND ABOLISH DISCRIMINATORY
PUBLIC POLICIES THROUGHOUT THIS
NATION HE ATE IT IN THE REPEAL
OF JIM CROW LAWS IN SOUTHERN
STATES. HE HELPED SHEPHERD THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT HI. REALLY WE
SAY WE'RE DEMOCRACY OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY YEARS BUT
REALLY WE'RE ONLY FIFTY FIVE
YEARS BECAUSE IT WAS NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE WHEN AFRICAN
AMERICANS GOT THE RIGHT. TO
VOTE. AND BROUGHT TO THIS
NATION'S ATTENTION ATTENTION
DISCRIMINATORY BANKING AND
HOUSING POLICIES AND PRACTICES.
KNOWN AS REDLINING SOME STILL.
PRACTICE TODAY. DR KING ALSO
BECAME ONE OF THE MOST NOTABLE
NONVIOLENT LEADERS AND WORLD
HISTORY STATING NONVIOLENCE IS
THE ANSWER TO THE CRUEL
POLITICAL AND MORAL QUESTIONS
OF OUR TIME HE UNDERSTOOD THAT
DOLE'S IN OPPOSITION OF CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WILL RESIST
OFTEN VIOLENTLY. AS WE SAW
AGAIN LAST WEEK IN WASHINGTON
DC NONE THE LESS DR KING
RESPONDED AN ACT TO ACTS OF
VIOLENCE BY CREATING A DIALOGUE
THAT WOULD HEAL RACIAL WOUNDS
ENCOURAGE UNDERSTANDING AND
UNIFIED. UNIFIED THE MASSES.
FINALLY AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
DR KING WAS A TRUTH TELLER. NO
MATTER HOW CONVENIENT OR
INCONVENIENT THOSE TROOPS WERE
DR KING WAS ALWAYS WILLING TO
SPEAK CANDIDLY. HE WAS ALWAYS
WILLING TO SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT N. THE
OTHER AMERICA SPEECH DR KING
SIX STATED I BELIEVE THAT
FREEDOM IS THE BONUS YOUR
RECEIPT FOR TELLING THE TRUTH
YOU SHALL KNOW THE TRUTH AND
THE TRUTH SHALL SET YOU FREE.
AND I DO NOT SEE HOW WE WILL
EVER SAW THE TURBULENT PROBLEMS
OR RACE CONFRONTING OUR NATION
UNTIL THERE IS AN HONEST
CONFRONTATION. WITH IT. IN A
WILLING SEARCH FOR TRUTH AND A
WILLINGNESS TO ADMIT THE TRUTH
WHEN WE DESERVE IT WHEN WE
DISCOVER IT. WE MUST LOOK TO DR
KING'S EXAMPLE AS A MORAL AND
ETHICAL. TOPICS TO HELP
CONFRONT THE PERSISTENT
INJUSTICES THAT PLAGUE THIS
NATION. THE INSANITY DEALER WE
SAW LAST WEEK. DOMESTIC
TERRORIST ATTACK ON OUR
NATION'S CAPITAL HAS MANY OF US
FEELING LIKE OUR DEMOCRACY IS
HANGING IN THE BALANCE THE
TRUTH IS BLACK AND BROWN FOLKS
OF WATCH THIS COUNTRY'S.
DEMOCRACY GO INTO A FREE FOR
ALL FOR FOUR YEARS. THE TAX AS
A RACIST INSURRECTION AIMED TO
DISENFRANCHISE ELIGIBLE VOTERS
MANY OF THE MILLIONS OF BLACK
AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THIS. NATION THAT
STILL BELIEVE THERE'S A PATH
FORWARD FOR COMPETENT AND
INCLUSIVE DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY.
DR KING OFTEN STATED. WE WILL
REMEMBER NOT THE WORDS OF OUR
ENEMIES. BUT THE SILENCE OF OUR
FRIENDS. FOR TOO MANY OF OUR
FRIENDS TODAY WHAT THE- DIS B.
I. YOUR NAME OURS BEHIND YOUR
NAME ARE SILENT ON THE ISSUES
THAT MATTER MOST THE DAY. AND
THAT SILENCE IS CRIMINAL. I
BELIEVE DR KING WOULD WANT US
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION THAT
THE GERMAN EFFORT TO INDOOR ANY
AND ALL CHALLENGES. IF IT MEANT
CREATING A MORE EQUAL AND JUST
SOCIETY FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
AS LAWMAKERS AND AS CITIZENS OF
THIS NATION. LET US
INDIVIDUALLY AND AS MEMBERS OF
THIS GREAT SENATE BODY.
EMBODIES THEM FOR MENTION
DEDICATED INDIVIDUAL SPIRIT AND
COMMITMENT TO TRUTH AND JUSTICE.
DR KING STATED. WHAT TIME IS
ALWAYS RIGHT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING LET'S DO THE RIGHT THING
TODAY COLLEAGUES NOT JUST BY
VOTING FOR THIS RESOLUTION BY
TRULY CELEBRATING DR KING BY T.
ENDING RACISM HATRED AND BIAS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS THAT
STILL EXISTS TODAY FIFTY THREE.
YEARS AFTER HIS DEATH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. WHILE ALSO SHAPED BY.
COMMENTS WITH THAT OF THE-
ARTICULATE SENATOR FROM GARDENA
AND ADD TO THEM. THE NOTION
THAT THE FRAMERS WHO SOUGHT TO
CREATE THIS GREAT GOVERNMENT
BOTH IN THE UNITED STATES IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT INFORMED BY AN
EFFORT. TO MAKE A MORE PERFECT
UNION. THAT OUR EFFORT EVERY
DAY HERE IN THIS CHAMBER ON
THIS FLOOR. TO ENGAGE IN PUBLIC
POLICY IN A MANNER TO MAKE IT A
MORE PERFECT UNION. THERE ARE
TIMES IN HISTORY WHERE PEOPLE
COME ALONG. THAT. HAVE AN
EXTRAORDINARY VOICE AN
EXTRAORDINARY ABILITY TO
ARTICULATE. AND EXPRESS THE
ESSENCE OF THAT MESSAGE THAT
WAS MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
HE WAS BORN IN A TIME. WHEN
THAT STRUGGLE WAS INFORMED BY
CIVIL RIGHTS. IN A WAY THAT
TORE THIS COUNTRY APART. BUT AS
THE SENATOR OF GARDENA
MENTIONED IN THIS PRAYER AND I
WANT TO REPEAT HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S THE
ESSENCE OF DR KING'S MESSAGE
WASN'T JUST ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
THAT HE WAS STRUCK FIGHTING
FOR. BUT FOR THE SOUL OF ALL OF
US. WE ARE TIED TOGETHER INTO A
SINGLE GARMENT OF DESTINY. JEWS
AND BLACKS IN IRISH ITALIANS
AND POLES AND LATINOS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IN BETWEEN WE'RE
ALL TIED TOGETHER INTO A SINGLE
GARMENT OF DESTINY CAUGHT IS
CAPABLE NETWORK OF MUTUALITY WE
ALL RISE TOGETHER AS WE ACT
RESPECTFULLY TOWARD EACH OTHER.
AND WHATEVER AFFECTS ONE
DIRECTLY AFFECTS ALL INDIRECTLY.
THOSE ARE ISSUES OF EQUITY AND
JUSTICE AND THE RICH AND THE
POOR AND ALL OF THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS WE DEBATE HERE TODAY.
AND SO THE QUESTION IS THIS. IT
CONCLUDES HIS BRIEF REMARKS IS.
WHAT CAN WE DO. AT THIS TIME IN
HISTORY. WE CAN LISTEN DEEPLY.
WE CAN SHOW RESPECT FOR PEOPLE
WITH DIFFERENT OPINIONS. WE CAN
DO WHAT HE DID IN THE FACE OF
BILLY CLUBS AND NOT ENGAGE IN
VIOLENCE. ENGAGING THE PURITY
OF ALL ALL OF THE ARGUMENTS. OF
THE VALUES WE SEEK. IT TOOK
FORTY TWO TIMES FOR THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT PASSED UNITED STATES
CONGRESS. THESE FIGHT SO LONG
AND DIFFICULT. BUT THE NAME OF
THE GAME FOR ALL OF US HERE
TODAY EVERYONE IS PRIVILEGED TO
REPRESENT NEARLY A MILLION
PEOPLE AT THIS TIME IN HISTORY.
IS TO IS TO BASICALLY EMBODY
THAT VALUE. AND TO UNDERSTAND.
IN EVERY RESPECT AS WE FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE FOR ONE WE FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE FOR ALL. BUT WE
NEED TO DO WHAT WITH MUTUALITY
WITH WITH DEEP LISTENING WITH
RESPECT. AND WITH AN ABILITY.
THAT WE ARE ALL IN THE
POSITION. THAT WE ARE HERE TO.
FOLLOW THE CREED OF THE FRAMERS
WHICH WAS TO FORM A MORE
PERFECT UNION. AND WE DO THAT
WITH OUR CONDUCT EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AND I THINK WE HAVE A
PERSON WHO IN OUR HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY. INFORMED AT A
TIME WHEN THEY WERE HIT THEM
OVER THE HEAD WITH BILLY CLUBS.
THE CONSTITUTION PERSONAL
CONSTITUTION TO STAY TRUE TO
NONVIOLENCE IS THAT TRUE TO HIS
MESSAGE. HAD TO BE INCLUSIVE OF
ALL OPPRESSION AGAINST ALL
PEOPLE EVEN THOUGH THE WORST
DEPRESSION WAS HAPPENING TO HIM
AND TO HIS FAMILY AND TO HIS
PARISHIONERS. I ASKED FOR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- I RISE TODAY
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS. IN
SUPPORT OF US SEE OUR SEX- THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. AND THE BLACK
COMMUNITY HAVE LONG HAD A
SHARED COMMITMENT TO FIGHT
AGAINST OPPRESSIVE OPPRESSION
RACISM AND NEVER TO REMAIN
SILENT. AS WELL AND WE REMAIN
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF THE
SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP- THE
JEWISH LEADERS SHARED. WITH DR
CHANG AND OF THE ROLE- THAT
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
PLAYED. IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. I WANTED TO SHARE A
FEW KEY MOMENTS THAT HIGHLIGHT.
THE SACRED BONDS WHICH CONTINUE
TO SERVICE OUR MORAL COMPASS.
DR KING- CHOSE RABBI- JOACHIM
PRINZ THE HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR
AND PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
JEWISH CONGRESS. TO SPEAK JUST
BEFORE DR KING DELIVERED HIS
HISTORIC I HAVE A DREAM SPEECH
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. RABBI
PRINCES ADDRESSES FOR HIS
ASSERTION THAT THE MOST URGENT
QUOTE THE MOST URGENT THE MOST
DISGRACEFUL. THE MOST SHAMEFUL
AND THE MOST TRAGIC PROBLEM. IS
SILENCE SILENCE OF BOTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE FOLLOWING YEAR MICHAEL
SCHWERNER JAMES CHANEY ANDREW
GOODMAN. TO JEWS AND A BLACK
MAN WERE LYNCHED WHILE TRYING
TO REGISTER BLACK VOTERS DURING
THE MISSISSIPPI FREEDOM SUMMER
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR. DR KING
SAID QUOTE THOSE MEN WHO HAVE
BEEN SILENT WHEN THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SPEAKING PARTICIPATED
IN THAT ACT. RABBI ABRAHAM
JOSHUA HESCHEL WHO IS PERHAPS
OUR MOST REVERED JEWISH CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVISTS MARCH ARM IN
ARM WITH DR KING FROM SELMA TO
MONTGOMERY. ON MARCH TWENTY
FIRST NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND
FAMOUSLY SAID QUOTE WHEN I
MARCH TO SELMA I FELT MY LEGS
WERE PRAYING AND QUOTE. RABBI
IN DR KING'S FRIENDSHIP RUN
DEEP. TEN DAYS BEFORE DR KING'S
MURDER. HE DELIVERED THE
KEYNOTE ADDRESS AT RABBI
HASSLES SIXTIETH BIRTHDAY
CELEBRATION. CALLING HIM QUOTE
A GREAT PROFIT AND ONE WHO
REFUSES TO REMAIN SILENT. IN
RETURN RABBI HESCHEL SAID QUOTE
MARTIN LUTHER KING IS A VOICE
OF VISION AND THE WAY I CALL
UPON EVERY JEW TO HEARKEN TO
HIS VOICE TO SHARE HIS VISION.
TO FOLLOW HIS WAY. THE WHOLE
FUTURE OF AMERICA WILL DEPEND
UPON THE IMPACT AND INFLUENCE
OF DOCTOR KING AND QUOTE. HIS
WORDS RING TRUE TODAY WE'RE ALL
DEEPLY INDEBTED TO THE LIFE
LEGACY AND FRIENDSHIP OF DR
KING. AND HIS HONOR WE RECOMMIT
OURSELVES NOT TO BE SILENT. AND
WE STAND WITH OUR BLACK
COLLEAGUES AND BLACK SHOES. TO
CONTINUE DR KING'S PURSUIT OF
JUSTICE. I ALSO JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT AS A LEGISLATURE- WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO STAND.
AGAIN STRUCTURAL RACISM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
TEAR DOWN. THE STRUCTURAL
RACISM THAT CONTINUES TO
AFFLICT OUR STATE AND HOUSING
AND EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE
AND IN A RACIST CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND THAT MEANS
ACTION. NOT JUST WORDS AS WE
SAY IN JUDAISM MAY HIS MEMORY
BE A BLESSING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AIBO. CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO SUPPORT S. SIERRA SIX
AND CELEBRATE THE LIFE OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR A
LITTLE OVER NINETY TWO YEARS
AGO DR KING WAS BORN INTO A
WORLD THAT WELL DIFFERENT FROM
OURS IN MANY WAYS IT'S STILL
EXHIBITS SOME SIMILARITIES. THE
SECOND OF THREE CHILDREN HE WAS
BORN IN ATLANTA GEORGIA TO THE
REVEREND MARTIN LUTHER KING C.
SENIOR AND ALBERTA KING HE WAS
RAISED IN A DISCIPLINED HOME
WHO WAS EDUCATED IN BIBLICAL
SCRIPTURE THE WORD OF GOD WAS
THE FOUNDATION OF HIS LIFE AND
THAT PHASE LATER IN LIFE THAT
WOULD INSPIRE A MASSIVE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT THAT WAS AIMED
AT ACHIEVING SOCIAL EQUALITY
FOR ALL OF GOD'S. CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF RACE. THE KING
LIVE IN AND SEE. AND YOU LIFE.
INSPIRE BECAUSE DESPITE THE
DISCRIMINATION THAT HE RECEIVED
FROM THE WORLD HE WAS BORN INTO
HE CHOSE TO FIGHT EQUALITY WITH
LOVE. UNIQUE BECAUSE HIS LARGER
THAN LIFE FIGURE OF WHO HE WAS
IS A STORY THAT MANY PEOPLE CAN
RELATE TO. AT THE END OF THE
DAY COLLEAGUES WE'RE ALL HUMAN.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT POLITICAL
IDEOLOGIES RACIAL MAKEUPS SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUSES AND RELIGIOUS
IDEAS BUT THEY DON'T DO THEY
DON'T DIFFERENTIATE US FROM
EACH OTHER THEY MAKE US A
VARIATION OF THE SAME THING. A
HUMAN. AND ONE OF GOD'S
CHILDREN. IN HIS I HAVE A DREAM
SPEECH GIVEN ON AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTH NINETEEN SIXTY THREE DR
KING KEPT THIS IN MIND AS HE
INVITE AS HE ADVISED HIS
MOVEMENT. AND I QUOTE. IN THE
PROCESS OF GAINING OUR RIGHTFUL
PLACE WE MUST NOT BE GUILTY OF
WRONGFUL DEEDS. LET US NOT SEEK
TO SATISFY OUR THIRST FOR
FREEDOM BY DRINKING FROM THE
CUP OF BITTERNESS AND HATRED.
WE MUST FOREVER CONDUCT OUR
STRUGGLE ON THE HIGH PLANE OF
DIGNITY AND DISCIPLINE. WE MUST
NOT ALLOW OUR CREATIVE PROTEST
TO DEGENERATE INTO PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE AGAIN AND AGAIN WE
MUST RISE TO THE MAJESTIC
HEIGHTS OF MEETING PHYSICAL
FORCE WITH SOUL FORCE. JUST AS
OUR NATION FINDS ITSELF ONCE
AGAIN IN A DIFFICULT MOMENT. I
PRAY THAT WE TAKE THESE WORDS
OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING TO
HEART. DR KING IS THE EXAMPLE
OF WHAT LOVE CAN DO IN THE FACE
OF HATRED. DR KING IS THE
EXAMPLE OF WHAT PEACE CAN DO IN
THE FACE OF VIOLENCE. AND DR
KING IS THE TRUE EXAMPLE OF
WHAT TRUTH CAN DO IN THE CASE
OF LIES. IT'S WE CELEBRATE
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR DAY
MONDAY AND THIS WEEKEND I
BELIEVE THE LEGACY THAT DR KING
AND WHAT HE STOOD FOR IS MORE
IMPORTANT. THAN ANY TIME IN
HISTORY IT HAS EVER BEEN. CAN I
ASK YOU TO DEDICATE LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THERE GARDENA
SAID. DR KING'S LIFE WAS A LIFE
OF SERVICE. SO INSTEAD OF JUST
TAKING MONDAY OFF AS A HOLIDAY.
FIND SOME WAY TO GIVE BACK TO
YOUR COMMUNITY AND SERVE THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT THANK
YOU. SENATOR EDMUND I. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YEAH IT'S A
IT'S INTERESTING I HATE THAT I
RISE ON THE FIRST TIME TO SPEAK
ON THIS FLOOR IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION MARTIN LUTHER
KING HAS BEEN ONE OF MY
PERSONAL FAVORITE HEROES IN MY
LIFE AND IN FACT WHEN I TAUGHT
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZING CLASS.
IN PORTLAND I USE THAT LETTER
FROM THE BIRMINGHAM JAIL AS THE
FOUNDATION IT'S JUST ALL ABOUT
HOW DO WE ORGANIZE HOW DO WE
ORGANIZE AGAINST INJUSTICE HOW
DO WE DO IT WITH LOVE IN OUR
HEARTS AND HOW DO WE DO IT WITH
TRUTH. IN OUR WORDS. I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS ALTHOUGH I'M A MEMBER OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN THE
LATINO CAUCUS THE LGBT CAUCUS.
ALL OF THOSE CARCASSES WERE
REPRESENTED BY THE WORDS OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING. AND IT'S
INTERESTING TO ME THAT HE DIED
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND THE
L. G. B. T. STOLE ALL RIGHTS
BEGAN IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
THAT HIS DEATH AND IN MANY WAYS
WAS WAS A MORE OF A CLARION
CALL TO CONTINUE THE WORK THAT
HE HAD DONE. COMING IN TODAY I
WAS LISTENING TO A- PODCAST ON
THE STEPS OF THE THINGS THAT.
AND ONE OF THE PEOPLE SPEAKING
TALKED ABOUT HOW. IF NOBODY
WANTED TO HURT YOU THEN WHAT WE
REALLY DOING. BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
TIME IS THAT IS THAT IS THAT WE
KNOW. THE POWER OF THE WORD OF
TRUTH. OF JUSTICE OR THINGS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE HISTORICALLY
FOUGHT BACK AGAINST BECAUSE FOR
SOME. JUSTICE IS MORE LIKE A
PIECE OF PIE OR PIZZA THAT IF
SOMEBODY ELSE HAS MORE THAT
MEANS YOU HAVE LESS. DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING PUSH BACK AGAINST
THOSE IDEAS AND KNEW THAT. THE
WAY FOR ALL OF US TO RISE AGAIN
AND THE WAY FOR ALL OF US. TO
BE OUR FULL SELVES AND THEREBY
CREATE. OUR MOST PERFECT UNION
IS ONE ALL OF OUR VOICES COUNT.
WHEN WE DON'T JUST. THINK ABOUT
THE CULT OF AN INDIVIDUAL. DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING WE STILL
SPEAK ABOUT HIM TODAY NOT
BECAUSE OF HIS PERSONALITY NOT
BECAUSE OF THE CULT OF HIS
PERSONALITY BUT BECAUSE OF HIS
WORDS AND HIS DEEDS AND HIS
LOVE. SO LET US ALL WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING I'M GOING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY IN THESE TIMES RIGHT
NOW WHEN SOME OF US FEEL.
TARGETS BECAUSE WE HAVE
DIFFERENT IDEAS AND OTHERS FEEL
LIKE THEIR TARGETS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE IDEA IS STRONG
ENOUGH. THAT WE ALL REMEMBER.
THAT WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO DO IS TO CREATE THAT MORE
PERFECT UNION WHERE WE ARE ALL
INCLUDED WHAT WE ALL CAN TALK
ABOUT IDEAS. IN CIVIL MANNER
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR CHILDREN CAN
GO TO SCHOOL TOGETHER AND BE
SAFE TOGETHER AND LOVE WHOMEVER
THEY CARED A LOT OF. SO I RISE
TODAY ON THIS DAY AND WE'RE
STILL LOOKING AT ROCKY ROAD
AHEAD OF US MEMBERS AS WE'RE
STILL LOOKING AT THAT BUT WE
KNOW THAT WE DO IT WITH
GOODNESS IN OUR HEARTS WE KNOW
THAT WE DO IT AS SERVANTS AND
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE DOING IT.
AND THE MOUNTAINS THAT WERE
CLIMBING RIGHT NOW ARE ONLY
THERE BECAUSE THE MOUNTAINS OF
HATE HAVE BEEN. FORGED AGAIN
AND THE ONLY THING THAT WILL
TEAR THEM DOWN IS TO CONTINUE
TO MARCH FORWARD ARM IN ARM. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GUARD YOU KNOW
MIGHT BE THE ONLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN SENATOR HERE BUT HE IS
CERTAINLY NOT THE ONLY CENTRE
WILLING TO WALK SIDE BY SIDE.
ARM IN ARM AS WE MAKE THAT
RAINBOW COURT COALITION. AS WE
FOLLOW THAT ARC TOWARDS JUSTICE
I ASK FOR YOUR ITEM. SENATOR
DRAWS A. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT DONE FIRST THE POINT
OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I WANT TO
SAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO MY
GRANDDAUGHTER SENECA. I
REMEMBER THE DAY THAT I SHE WAS
BORN I WAS AT OUR LABOR DAY BY
LUTHER KING BREAKFAST AND I GOT
THE CALL AND I JUMPED IN THE
CAR AND TOOK OFF. TO SEE HER
BEING BORN WHAT AN HONOR FOR
HER. BUT AS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
RISE. IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
R. SIX. WHICH COMMEMORATES THE
LIFE AND THE LEGACY OF REVEREND
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
COLLEAGUES WHEN WORKERS ARE
FORCED TO STRIKE. WE SHOULD
REMEMBER HOW DR KING RESPONDED
TO GARBAGE WORKERS IN MEMPHIS.
WHEN WORKERS HE JOINED THEM HE
INSPIRED THEM HE MARCHED WITH
THEM AND HE WAS ASSASSINATED
FOR DOING SO. WHEN WORKERS ARE
THREATENED WITH LOSING THEIR
JOBS BECAUSE THEY ARE
ORGANIZING WE SHOULD REMEMBER
HOW DR KING RESPONDED TO THOSE
THREATS. HE WALKED ACROSS THE
BRIDGE IN SELMA. HE WAS JAILED
IN BIRMINGHAM. AND HIS COURAGE
GAVE PEOPLE THE COURAGE TO
ORGANIZE THEMSELVES. WHEN
WORKERS ARE DENIED HEALTH CARE
SIX DAYS OR HAZARD PAY DURING
THE PANDEMIC. WE ASK EACH OF
YOU TO REMEMBER WHAT DR KING
SAID QUOTE. OF ALL THE FORMS OF
INEQUALITY. INJUSTICE AND
HEALTH IS THE MOST SHOCKING AND
INHUMANE. WHEN WORKERS STAND UP
FOR FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES. WE
ASK EACH OF YOU TO NEVER FORGET
DR KING'S VERY LAST SPEECH. HE
SAID DO YOU KNOW THAT MOST OF
THE POOR PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY
ARE WORKING EVERY DAY. IT IS
CRIMINAL TO HAVE PEOPLE WORKING
ON A FULL TIME BASIS GETTING
PART TIME INCOME. WE HONOR DR
KING BEST BUY STANDING UP AND
USING THE POWER OF OUR VOTE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES THANK YOU.
SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENTS AND SENATORS- I WILL
FIRST OF ALL I THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM ARGENTINA FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ABSOLUTION FORD AND PROUD TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION IS CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. MARTIN
LUTHER KING CERTAINLY WAS- A
LEADER FOR ALL WHO WON THE
FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS- I KNOW
MANY API STOOD WITH HIM- IN
FACT I BELIEVE IN SELMA OTHER
PHOTOS OF HIM WEARING. HAWAIIAN
LEIS BECAUSE THEY WERE
PRESENTED TO HIM TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY. THEM AND- THANKS TO
HIS WORK AND THOSE OF MANY
OTHERS AND THE- SO RIGHTS
MOVEMENT THE BLACK CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT- WE SAW- API CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS EMERGE-
FOLLOWING THE EXAMPLE OF MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND OTHER BLACK
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS. AS WELL
SO WE OWE OUR MOVEMENT TO
MARTIN LUTHER KING AND THE
BLACK COMMUNITY. I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT MARTIN LUTHER KING-
WAS A MAN WHO- SPOKE WITH MORAL
AUTHORITY HE SPOKE ABOUT FACTS
AND DO NOT NEED TO DENY. HIM
TALK ABOUT THINGS ON VIOLENTLY.
AND T. APPEALED TO THE- GOOD
WELL AND THE MORE AUTHORITY
THAT HE HOPED THAT EACH ONE OF
US HAD HE BELIEVED IN AMERICA
AND AMERICANS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT HIS OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND THOSE OF HIS
FOLLOWERS- DO NOT NCESSARILY.
INSPIRE SUCH CONFIDENCE BUT HE
ACTUALLY BELIEVED THAT BY
SPEAKING OUT AND ACTING
NONVIOLENTLY THAT THE OUR
BETTER NATURES WOULD EVENTUALLY
EMERGE AND AT LEAST A MAJORITY
OF AMERICANS WOULD STAND WITH
HIM. AND WELL UNFORTUNATELY-
THOSE WHO OPPOSED HIM- FINALLY
TOOK HIS LIFE. HE HIMSELF HIS
IDEAS REMAIN IMMORTAL. BECAUSE
MMHM BECAUSE HE BELIEVED IN US
AND WE NEED TO BELIEVE IN
OURSELVES NOW AS WE ARE AS I'M
SPEAKING HERE- WE HAVE A CHAIN
LINK FENCE SURROUNDING THE
CAPITAL WE JUST SAW WHAT WE
WHAT WE JUST WITNESSED ACTS OF
VIOLENCE IN OUR U. S. CAPITOL
IN DC- THERE ARE THOSE WHO
UNFORTUNATELY- ARE STILL
CALLING FOR VIOLENCE AND I
THINK WE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT-
VIOLENCE IS NOT. THE WAY AND
THAT THOSE PEOPLE OF GOOD WILL.
WHO NEED TO STAND UP AND SAY
THIS IS NOT THE WAY WE DO
THINGS AND I THINK MARTIN
LUTHER KING IS A MAN WHO IS A
EXAMPLE OF THAT AND- HE DID
LOSE HIS LIFE- WE NEED TO TAKE
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT- BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO CALL ON. ALL TO
STAND STRONG. AND SPEAK OUT.
AND CONTINUE TO- APPEAL TO THAT
MORAL AUTHORITY THAT MARTIN
LUTHER KING SAID AS AN EXAMPLE
FOR US. SO AGAIN I URGE AND A
STRONG SUPPORT FOR IT SEE OUR
SIX NO ONE AGAIN THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FOR. THIRTY ENOUGH FOR
BRING THIS FOR TODAY THANK YOU.
SENATOR. THANK YOU WHEN I MAKE
SURE YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GUARDIAN AS WELL AS WELL AS THE
REST OF THE BLACK LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS FOR THEIR BEAUTIFUL
EVENT THIS WEEK THAT I
ATTENDED. WHAT AN INCREDIBLE
WAY TO CELEBRATE THE LIFE AND
LEGACY OF DR KEY ESPECIALLY
AFTER A WEEK THAT WE'VE HAD
WHAT WE DO NEED TO SEE MORE
JUSTICE AND UNITY- I REMEMBER
AS A COLLEGE STUDENT READING
ONE OF MY MOST FAVORITE BOOKS
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WHY WE
CAN'T WAIT. ABOUT THE LIFE AND
LEGACY OF DR KING HE TALKED
ABOUT A NEW DAY REVOLUTION FOR
EQUITY UNITY AND HEALING
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED NOW IT'S
ALMOST AS HISTORY IS REPEATING
ITSELF- AND WE HAVE A WAY TO
CELEBRATE. TOGETHER WITH HIS.
WORDS IN THIS BOOK. SO I USE
THAT AS THOMPSON AS A DOC. TO
KIND OF RE. ON THE Y. WE NEED
TO. I'M AND THINKING- HIS WORDS
ON UNITY AND ACT IN HERE. I DO
WANT TO READ SOMETHING THAT SHE
MEANT- IN THIS IT'S LIKE JUST A
QUICK COOK MEN THAT FREEDOM IS
MORE WE GET BY THE OPPRESSOR IT
MUST BE IT BY THE A- AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON SO
ELOQUENT YOU KNOW AFTER THE
EQUITY- SEEMS LIKE WE'RE TAKING
SOMETHING BUT IT'S REALLY JUST
TO GET OUR FAIR SHARE AND SO I
WANT TO THINK AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA AND
THANK ALL OF AMAZING WORDS LIKE
WHICH. CENTERED THANK YOU MA'AM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM GARDEN WHO ALWAYS SAYS
SUCH AN ELOQUENT JOB AND NOT
END UP PAYING TRIBUTE TO MARTIN
LUTHER KING I THINK THAT THIS
YEAR MLK THE HOLIDAY AND HIS
THE DAY OF HIS DEATH IT'S EVEN
MORE POIGNANT THAN IT EVER HAS
BEFORE IT MAKES ME THINK ABOUT
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT
AND ALL OF THE PROTESTS THAT WE
SAW OVER THE SUMMER AND HOW
MUCH WORK WE STILL HAVE TO DO
AND THESE PROTESTS WERE NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA. THEY WERE
NOT JUST IN THE UNITED STATES
THEY WERE ALL OVER THE ENTIRE
WORLD AND HERE WE STAND FIFTY
THREE YEARS LATER AND WE
HAVEN'T HEEDED DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING'S WORDS AND I JUST THINK
THAT WE HAVE SO MUCH WORK TO DO
AND WE STAND HERE AND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT RIGHTLY SO WHAT AN
AMAZING INDIVIDUAL AND MAN HE
WAS AND THE EXAMPLE THAT HE
SAT. BUT WE NEED TO DO THE SAME
IF NOT US THEN WHO AND IF NOT
WIN NOW THEN WHEN AND I WILL
LEAVE YOU WITH MY FAVORITE
MARTIN LUTHER KING QUOTE WHICH
I USUALLY REPEAT EVERY YEAR
DARKNESS CANNOT DRIVE CANNOT
DRIVE OUT DARKNESS ONLY LIGHT
CAN DO THAT HATE CANNOT DRIVE
OUT HATE ONLY LOVE CAN DO THAT
SO LET'S GO FORWARD IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH LOVE IN OUR
HEART AND IT'S FINALLY SETTLE
THIS RACIAL ISSUE THAT HAS
PLAGUED AMERICA FOR SO LONG.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER.
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE MADAM
PRO TEM. WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANTED TO
RISE ALSO TO SPEAK ON S. C. R.
SIX SO I APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION. YOU KNOW I'D
PROBABLY BECAUSE THE REMARKS
THAT YOU HAVE MADE HERE TODAY
REALLY ARE INSPIRATIONAL. AND I
THINK ASPIRATIONAL. AFTER A
YEAR OF CRISIS THAT'S EXPOSED
AND EXACERBATED THE INJUSTICES
IN OUR SOCIETY I THINK IT'S
FITTING THAT WE JOIN ONCE AGAIN
TO HONOR A MAN WHO SPENT HIS
ENTIRE SHORT LIFE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE JUSTICE THROUGH
NONVIOLENT PEACEFUL PROTEST.
TODAY WE ARE REMINDED OF A
JANUARY FIFTY FIVE YEARS AGO
WHEN REVEREND KING MOVED HIS
FAMILY INTO A HOUSING PROJECT
IN CHICAGO TO HELP HIGHLIGHT
THE RACIAL DISPARITIES AND
PROMOTE MORE SAFE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AFTER SEVERAL PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATIONS INCLUDING ONE
WHERE HE WAS HIT IN THE HEAD
WITH A ROCK REVEREND KING WON
SOME HOUSING CONCESSIONS FROM
THAT CITY. HE CALLED IT THE
FIRST STEP IN A JOURNEY OF A
THOUSAND MILES. AND FOR MANY OF
US IN THIS ROOM IT MAY FEEL
LIKE OUR JOURNEYS TO FIGHT FOR
BETTER HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND EQUAL RIGHTS
FOR ALL. AND MANY OTHER
CRITICAL ISSUES HAVE MORPHED
INTO ONE MILLION MILES. IT MAY
FEEL LIKE WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING
THE SAME FIGHT SINCE OUR
COUNTRY'S BIRTH THE SAME FIGHTS
MLK FOUGHT BEFORE HIS DEATH.
BUT EACH STEP. FORWARD EACH
STEP THAT IMPROVES THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS. OF AMERICANS OF
ALL PEOPLE NO MATTER HOW MANY
STEPS THERE ARE MATTERS. TODAY
IN HONOR OF THE GREAT REVERENCE
KING'S NINETY SECOND BIRTHDAY I
HOPE WE CAN ALL FIND A RENEWED
SENSE OF INSPIRATION IN HIS
TEACHINGS ESPECIALLY NOW.
ESPECIALLY NOW AND MAKE A
RENEWED COMMITMENT WITHIN
OURSELVES. PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY AND ON BEHALF OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
TO MOVE CALIFORNIA FORWARD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU AND I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES- FOR
YOUR WORDS OF INSPIRATION- YOUR
WORDS OF TRUTH YOUR WORDS OF
BELIEF. AND THAT WHICH DR KING
STOOD FOR AND STILL STAND FOR
TODAY. AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
THOSE WORDS ARE JUST NOT. WITH
US TODAY BUT AS WE LEAVE THIS
CHAMBER AND CARRY ON OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE TRULY
STRIVE TO ACHIEVE. THE AMERICA
THAT DR KING. PRAY FOR. THE
DOCTOR KING DREAM FOR AND SADLY
DR KING DIED FOR. IT'S AMERICA
THAT WE HAVE YET TO ACHIEVE.
BUT WHAT HOPE AND PROMISE AND
DEDICATION WE WILL. DR KING
OFTEN STAYED THE WHOLE TIME IT
TEST OF A MAN. DOES NOT WORRY
STANTON COMFORT AND CONVENIENCE
BUT WHERE HE STANDS IN TIMES OF
CHALLENGE AND CONTROVERSY WE
STAND IN THAT LARGE TODAY MY
FRIENDS AND WHAT ARE WE GONNA
DO DURING THESE TIMES OF
CHALLENGE AND CONTROVERSY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON S. C. R. SIX. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS HI
BACKER. I PORCHES I BRADFORD I
HAVE A YELLOW I CORTESE I DALLY.
I DON FIVE THE RISER HI ADNAN
I. GROWTH. I HURTS. BY WAY SO.
HURTADO JONES I LAYERED I LLEVA
I LIVE ALONE. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S BY NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN.
HI A SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAM I
PERSON TINA FIVE ROTH I RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER AMBERG HI MY
CASKEY FIVE WINNER. I WILL HI.
HIGHS THIRTY NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION PASSES. THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR
COLLEAGUES I HOPE YOU GO HOME
AND HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND
WITH YOUR FAMILIES AND SAFELY
IN YOUR COMMUNITIES AS WE HONOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING- AND MOVE
INTO NEXT WEEK THE FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
TUESDAY JANUARY NINETEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWO PM BE
SAFE MEMBERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WIL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE TUESDAY AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND EVERYBODY
HAPPY MARTIN LUTHER KING DAY.